after a night of desperate searching
through the rubble the scrap for signs
of life continued
the pakitika province has faced sheer
destruction and beneath the homes made
of mud bricks and wood it's feared many
bodies
have been fully destroyed and many
people are wounded all the houses have
been demolished and now we need tents
and all the other necessary items
the problem now is getting a
sophisticated rescue operation underway
in this remote mountainous region and
aid too
after a plea for international support
by the taliban neighboring pakistan and
iran have sent trucks and planes packed
with supplies while several other
countries say they're ready to provide
assistance
but those on the ground say they need
more urgently
we have nothing not even a tent to live
in
those who were airlifted to safety after
the government sent helicopters are now
in crowded hospitals across the region
without a major international aid
presence treating people is proving
difficult
i've lost 26 of my family members like
my cousins and close relatives
even my own children were killed
we have received 35 injured until now
most of the injured are women
there are some men and three children as
well
some of the injured have been
transferred to the regional hospital in
ghazni province after receiving the
first aid here
rest of the injured are here and they
are under our treatment
and for those who haven't survived this
catastrophic quake
this is the result
the un one of the very few aid agencies
that remained after the taliban takeover
last year says the country and the
government aren't equipped to deal with
this natural disaster
and so a country already suffering and
abandoned by much of the world
finds itself struggling now more than
ever